bonsoir à tous bon week end voici les
titres de l'actualité de ce samedi
une actualité marquée par la disparition
dramatique du président polonais lech
kaczinsky la disparition dans le crash
de l'avion qui le conduisait en russie
pour une cérémonie avec lui près de 100
personnes ont perdu la vie son épouse et
plusieurs dignitaires polonais étaient
également à bord nous irons à moscou et
à varsovie dans un instant c'est une
tempête judiciaire qui s'annonce
désormais en vendée et en
charente-maritime après la décision de
raser plus de 1500 maisons
une partie de la population concernée
prépare avec ses avocats vous le verrez
la contre attaque
la main passe au front national jean
marie le pen ne se lancera plus dans une
bataille présidentielle
la course à sa succession est ouverte en
lice deux candidats à sa fille marine et
bruno gollnisch
les militants font leur choix à
l'automne prochain depuis deux heures
maintenant
le saint suaire le tissu de lin qui
aurait recouvert le corps du christ est
à nouveau exposé au public à turin une
relique qui pourrait attirer dans les
semaines à venir 2 millions de fidèles
un week-end de printemps au soleil des
températures qui grimpe allant jusqu'à
22 degrés à bordeaux nous irons
justement sur le bassin d'arcachon
prendre un peu l'air tout à l'heure
enfin le cinéma nous retrouverons la fin
de ce journal la comédienne américaine
égérie des magazines féminins jennifer
aniston de passage à paris elle est
venue nous présenter son dernier film
cela s'appelle chasseur de primes
les drapeaux en berne sur varsovie un
pays en deuil la pologne est sous le
choc ce soir après la mort brutale de
son président lech kaczinsky disparition
tragique à la suite du crash ce matin de
son avion alors qu'ils devraient
atterrir à smolensk en russie
celui ci est accompagné de son épouse
mais également d'une importante
délégation polonaise
il y avait à bord une centaine de
passagers et il n'y a aucun survivant
avant de prendre la direction de
varsovie et de moscou retour sur la
catastrophe avec arnauld miguet
des morceaux c'est dans la forêt voilà
tout ce qui reste de l'appareil qui
transportait le président polonais les
secours dépêchés sur place tout près de
l'aéroport de smolensk à l'ouest de la
russie n'ont rien pu faire
il y avait 96 passagers à bord aucun
survivre j'ai vu cet avion qui volait
très bas
je me suis dit qu'il y avait vraiment
quelque chose qui n'allait pas on est
passé au ras des arbres
et puis les couper tout sur son passage
et tout d'un coup j'ai entendu un grand
boum une explosion comme une bombe
le tupolev-154 ici au décollage de
varsovie dans lequel voyageait lech
kaczinsky le chef de l'état est une
délégation de hauts dignitaires polonais
tente pour la quatrième fois de se poser
malgré les ordres des aiguilleurs du
ciel qui juge la visibilité trop faible
peu avant 11h ce matin il s'écrase les
autorités russes ordonne sur le champ
une enquête retrouve les deux boîtes
noires mais une erreur de pilotage
serait bien à l'origine de la
catastrophe
le président polonais se rendaient à
cette cérémonie de commémoration du
massacre de katyn en 1940 des milliers
d'officiers et intellectuels polonais
avaient été exécutés ici par les
soviétiques
aujourd'hui katyn est à nouveau le lieu
d'une tragédie polonaise
les réactions internationales sont bien
sûr nombreuses paris londres berlin
washington jérusalem ont exprimé leurs
condoléances au peuple polonais il
s'agit en tout cas d'une situation
extrêmement rare outre le chef de l'état
et les principaux chefs de l'armée il y
avait également à bord plusieurs députés
et le président de la banque centrale du
pays
alors voyons ce soir comment le pays
justement réagi direction varsovie avec
claude son père des prieurs et quelques
chants dès l'annoncé de l'accident de
l'avion
des centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées devant le palais
présidentiel
parmi les fleurs et les bougies une fois
que du président de son épouse sur tous
les visages
la même tristesse le même désarroi
c'est le meilleur président qu'on ait
jamais c'est dur on est là pour se
rassembler pour se consoler ensemble on
est tous sous le choc
c'est difficile de parler mon coeur est
brisé
dans toute la ville
les drapeaux ont été mis en berne
partout le même recueillement
le gouvernement s'est réuni d'urgence
pour déterminer la marche à suivre au
début de la réunion
tous les membres présents observent une
minute de silence
quelques instants plus tard le premier
ministre s'adresse à la nation c'est pas
de cave à l'afp ce chef qui tous les
polonais vivent aujourd'hui une grande
tragédie l'une des plus importantes de
l'histoire de notre nation
c'est l'événement le plus tragique de
l'histoire de la pologne entendent
dernière
en fin de journée plusieurs cérémonies
religieuses se sont déroulées dans tout
le pays
la cathédrale de varsovie était entouré
par une foule très impressionnante
le gouvernement a annoncé une semaine de
deuil et on reste à varsovie où l'on
retrouve notre envoyé spécial ce soir
nos goûters
bonsoir no alors parlez nous de cette
émotion de cette atmosphère ce soir dans
un pays on sait extrêmement croyants oui
c'est vrai que cette émotion est
palpable un peu partout le recueillement
s'organise dans plusieurs points de la
ville actuellement une messe a lieu à la
cathédrale de varsovie ils sont quelques
10000 personnes dans le bâtiment mais
aussi tout autour
et ici devant la présidence de la
république nous nous sommes positionnés
et bien il ya encore cinq mille
personnes qui sont là dans un silence
très impressionnants ils sont venus avec
des bougies colorées avec des bouquets
de fleurs et bien sûr lorsqu'on les
interroge ils pleurent leur président
mais surtout il se pose des questions ce
président était allé commémorer le
massacre de katyn
une bête noire dans l'histoire de la
pologne comment se fait-il qu on puisse
vivre une tragédie pareille encore
aujourd'hui on peut voir notamment sur
certains drapeaux qu'il ya deux dates
d'inscrites 1940 et 2010 alors la crise
politique est tel que bien sûr le
premier ministre donald tusk a organisé
une réunion de crise actuellement le
président de la république par intérim
et le président de la chambre basse du
parlement
et c'est lui qui va devoir dans les
semaines qui viennent dans les deux mois
et demi exactement organiser une
nouvelle élection présidentielle
merci arnaud direction maintenant moscou
avec notre correspondant laurent
boussier bonsoir laurent les autorités
russes ont très vite exprimé leurs
réserves sur le choix du pilote qui a
finalement tenté d'atterrir à quatre
reprises sur cet aéroport militaire oui
alors évidemment que les deux boîtes
noires vont être décryptés dans les
prochains jours mais effectivement
l'enquêté s'oriente vers une erreur
humaine une erreur du pilote qui malgré
le brouillard et les demandes réitérées
des contrôleurs russes s'est obstiné à
vouloir atterrit alors une erreur
humaine ça veut dire soit une erreur de
pilotage
l'avion arrivait trop bas ou trop
lentement près de la piste soit une
erreur de décision après trois
tentatives d'atterrissage l'attenté une
quatrième tentative d'atterrissage n'est
pas forcément la meilleure idée
autre point laurent le
premier ministre vladimir poutine a très
vite décidé de se rendre sur les lieux
du drame où absolument les deux des deux
plus hauts responsables russe dimitri
medvedev et vladimir poutine ont été les
premiers à appeler au téléphone le
premier ministre polonais t ce matin ils
ont évidemment présenté toutes les
condoléances
mais les deux plus hauts dignitaires
sont allés plus loin par solidarité avec
les polonais dimitri medvedev a parlé à
la télévision polonaise et à décrypter
et ici en russie une journée de deuil
national qui sera lundi prochain
quant à vladimir poutine il s'est
effectivement déjà rendus à smolensk où
il a sur le lieu du drame où il doit ce
soir rencontrer le premier ministre
polonais les deux hommes se connaissent
bien ils s'apprécient et puis enfin
dernière information
les corps des victimes de cette
catastrophe dont celui du président
polonais sont en ce moment même en train
d'être acheminés vers moscou
merci laurent bouvier en direct de
moscou alors revenons maintenant sur la
carrière le parcours de lech kaczinsky
histoire d'un destin assez incroyable
celui d'un homme et de son frère jumeau
qui ont gravi progressivement les
échelons du pouvoir anti communiste
devenu conservateur et dirigiste lech
kaczinsky était arrivé à la tête de
l'état en 2005 bernard lebrun la pologne
fut l'avant dernier des 27 pays de
l'union européenne à ratifier le traité
de lisbonne
tel un signe la presse polonaise
souligner à ce jour là la panne de style
ou du président kachine ski car c'est
bien un eurosceptique qui ratifiera du
bout des doigts le traité
en 2005 ce catholique conservateur que
l'on voit ici avec son épouse maria des
cdn aussi ce matin brigue avec succès la
présidence de la république
ce jeune grand père né après la guerre
achevée donc cette année son mandat
présidentiel de 5 durant sa présidence
il réalisa en juillet 2006 une première
mondiale dans un pays démocratique
lech kaczinsky à gauche à l'écran
désigne comme premier ministre son frère
jumeau jaroslaw kaczinsky alors leader
du parti politique droit et justice
l'épopée des deux jumeaux kaczinsky net
au cinéma ce film très populaire en
pologne les rendit définitivement
célèbre militant catholique
lech et jaroslaw s'engagent tous deux
près de lech walesa
dans le long combat du syndicat
solidarité après la chute du mur en 1989
ils deviennent conseiller du président
puis député tous deux élus sur les bancs
de la droite à la diète polonaise
pro-américain son premier voyage à
l'étranger fut pour george bush le
président kaczysnki teinte à célébrer
l'an dernier la date la plus importante
à ses yeux le dixième anniversaire de
l'entrée de la pologne dans les rangs de
l'otan l'alliance atlantique
et puis en france la communauté
polonaise de paris s'est rassemblée à
notre dame de l'assomption dans le 8e
arrondissement afin de se recueillir ils
ont déposé des bijoux des bougies et des
fleurs tout au long de la journée
voilà ce que l'on pouvait dire sur cette
catastrophe ce soir l'actualité en
france qui reste marqué aujourd'hui
encore par ces cartes qui dresse les
zones doivent zones noires du littoral
vendéen et charentais
plusieurs manifestations ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui par exemple la fouace à
l'aiguillon sur mer
une colère qui pourrait très vite
devenir judiciaire tour d'horizon de ces
protestations
avec caroline thébaux deluxe et ce
qu'ils considèrent être un second
traumatisme 350 habitants de fouras en
charente maritime ont manifesté
aujourd'hui pour protester contre le
classement en zone orange des dizaines
de maisons
cela veut dire une zone encore à
expertiser et donc de possibles et
démolition est fait à la va-vite à
l'emporte-pièce et c'est donc c'est hors
de question on ne peut pas supporter ce
genre de chose y'a aucune communication
s'est fait dans le dos des gens c'est
inadmissible là franchement juste
sentiment que le zonage qui était ce un
jeune âge qui a été fait est là a
certainement pas faire 80 km plus loin
en zone noire
la mobilisation est même devenue
judiciaire un habitant de
l'aiguillon-sur-mer a déposé plainte
cette semaine contre la mairie un acte
de révolte même si sa maison ne sera pas
détruite
pour lui la digue qui devait les
protéger des eaux a été négligée pense
que ça a été laissée est pas pris en
considération et le justement la vie et
la sécurité des habitants étaient mis en
jeu par rapport à cette négligence
à la faute-sur-mer l'autre commune la
plus touchée par la tempête xynthia
la résistance s'organise en présence
d'avocats et peut contester le zonage
c'est un droit tout à chacun c'est une
décision administrative comme toute
décision administrative elle peut être
contesté devant le tribunal
administratif
des habitants sont d'autant plus
perplexe que certains quartiers touchés
par la tempête ne font partie d'aucune
zone comme ce village huppé au nord de
l'île de ré où la digue a cédé un
quartier qui ne fera l'objet d'aucune
destruction ni de mesures spécifiques
on avait cru que les négociations entre
salariés dirigeants de l'usiné sodimatex
à crépy-en-valois était en bonne voie et
puis hier soir c'est une nouvelle
situation de blocage qui est apparu avec
à la clé la colère et un bras de fer qui
se poursuit la reprise des discussions
sur les indemnités de licenciement est
prévu pour lundi
la politique je pars le coeur tranquille
voilà les propos que jean marie le pen a
choisi dans le figaro magazine pour
annoncer son intention de ne pas se
lancer à nouveau dans une bataille
présidentielle
le président du front national qui passe
la main reste à savoir à qui eh bien ce
sont les militants qui répondront à
cette question les deux candidats sont
marine le pen l'héritière et bruno
gollnisch son soldat de toujours et la
nuque et sébastien laffargue ya quelques
jours avant les régionales
à 81 ans jean marie le pen réfutait
encore toute idée n'était pas je déteste
le mot retraite aussi bien dans le
vocabulaire civil que dans le militaire
les régionales sont un succès pour le
front national 17 % sur toute la france
23% pour jean marie le pen en paca un
retour gagnant en forme de bouquet final
cette fois l'heure de la retraite a
sonné s'il n'ya pas d'élection
présidentielle up du super g après j'ai
pris la décision de ne pas être candidat
lors de la prochaine présidentielle
l'un succession est donc ouverte avec
deux candidats déjà déclarés marine le
pen la fille et bruno vanier les fidèles
lieutenants
je crois je suis apte à prouver que
notre combat national est compatible
avec des valeurs universelles qu'il est
partagée par beaucoup en europe et même
hors d'europe
je crois que je suis apte aussi à
rassembler autour de ma personne
puisqu'ils candidate à la succession de
mon père donc je pense que c'est mon
devoir officiellement jean marie le pen
ce interdit d'afficher sa préférence
mais elle ne fait aucun doute
le front national est d'abord une
affaire de famille
aujourd'hui marine le pen a pris une
envergure qui n'était pas celle qu'elle
avait évidemment quand elle a quant elle
a éclos politiquement et je pense que
jean marie le pen a sans doute
considérer et repousser la date aussi de
son de sa succession a aujourd'hui parce
que justement ne la sentais pas prête
le jean marie le pen et lui seul avait
réussi à imposer l'extrême droite dans
le paysage politique
après 38 ans d'existence le front
national survivra-t-il au départ de son
fondateur
politique toujours et alain juppé
confirme son offre pour 2012 l'ancien
ministre de jacques chirac qui dans une
interview au journal le monde
en choisissant ses mots prend à nouveau
ses distances avec la politique du
président de la république
il affirme d'ailleurs qu'il n'a jamais
cru à la rupture tout en accordant à
nicolas sarkozy le statut de candidat
naturel de la droite pour la prochaine
présidentielle
en thaïlande le conflit est désormais
ouvert entre les militants de
l'opposition et l'armée
au moins 15 personnes auraient été tuées
et plus de 600 blessés dans les
affrontements qui ont eu lieu
aujourd'hui entre ce que l'on appelle
les chemises rouges et les militaires
ce soir washington appelle à la retenue
cette troublante affaire maintenant aux
états unis mère de 34 ans avait souhaité
il ya sept mois adoptée en russie un
enfant le jeune artem huit ans était
alors arrivée au sein de sa famille
d'accueil
mais aujourd'hui il a retrouvé son pays
d'origine et cela contre son gré sa mère
d'adoption tout simplement ne voulait
plus de lui
explications aurélia lima il a l'air
perdu et pour cause ce petit garçon de 8
ans est arrivée seule à l'aéroport de
moscou entre ses mains une lettre de sa
mère adoptive américaine demandait
l'annulation de l'adoption
l'enfant qui n'y auraient apparemment
tous des raisons de ce voyage répond ici
aux questions des services sociaux est
ce qu'elle te bat e
non mais le métier là les cheveux comme
ça tu pleurais oui aussi mieux il dit du
bien de sa famille adoptive un stage en
brun sa grand mère non jean grand père
de son grand frère aussi dès que je lui
pose des questions au sujet de sa mère
qui l'a rejeté il se met à pleurer
adopté il ya sept mois justin arten vive
est ici dans une petite ville du
tennessee
selon sa mère adoptive il présenterait
des troubles mentaux et serait dangereux
pour la famille
stupéfaction à l'orphelinat où montre
cette photo on y voit l'enfant jouer
avec celle qui va devenir sa mère qui
fait comme vous le voyez l'enfant souris
la mère a l'air heureuse il avait
développé une belle complicité
la mère américaine est passible de
poursuites mais la sphère complique
aussi les relations entre les etats-unis
et la russie qui a pris une décision
radicale de notre gouvernement souhaite
la plus grande fermeté dans cette
affaire nous allons geler toutes les
procédures d'adoption d'enfants russes
par des parents américains
le petit garçon déjà très fragilisée à
lui était de nouveau placé à
l'orphelinat sans autre perspective pour
l'instant et les vainqueurs 16 à suivre
dans un instant le saint suaire objet de
toutes les polémiques mais également de
toutes les passions réapparaît pour la
première fois depuis dix ans cela se
passe vous le verrez depuis quelques
heures à turin un samedi de sport
biarritz s'est invité cet après midi en
demi finale de la coupe d'europe de
rugby demain la grande classique paris
roubaix mais également le marathon de
paris
et puis le cinéma avec l'in térieur
suivent de jennifer aniston la
comédienne américaine est venue nous
présenter son dernier film lors de son
passage à paris son titre chasseur de
primes mais avant cela direction turin
donc où le saint suaire est à nouveau
exposé ce tissu de lin qui aurait
recouvert le corps du christ avait été
gardé à l'abri des regards depuis dix
ans
maintenant un mystère qui vous allez le
voir passionne toujours autant sur place
philippe visseyrias agent claudio
caldera le voici dans son coffre blindé
transparent à l'épreuve des balles et
des incendies sur ce drap de quatre
mètres de long que les croisés aurait
ramené d'orient on aperçoit la marque
d'un visage d'un corps demain et des
traces de sang pour l'archevêque de
turin son origine ne fait aucun doute
je suis convaincu que seul un seul a
enveloppé le corps de jésus est
aujourd'hui à turin on a déployé tous
les fastes de l'église pour honorer ce
linceul vénéré comme une relique messe
solennelle et foule recueillie
j'en ai encore le coeur qui bat je ne
m'attendais pas à quelque chose d'aussi
vivant à congés quand j'ai viva mais la
ferveur a dépassé les frontières de
l'italie
ces cavaliers arrive de chambéry en
savoie pour rappeler que le suaire leur
appartenait jusqu'au 16e siècle c'est
1578 quand le saint suaire est parti de
sa voix est venu à turin l'émotion elle
était justement le côté historique le
côté sa part de ce saint suaire
appartenait la maison de savoie
mais le suaire de turin c'est aussi une
bataille entre scientifiques en 1988 une
datation au carbone 14 montre que le
suaire serait un faux fabriqué au moyen
âge des analyses remise en cause depuis
par les chercheurs proche de l'église
alors dans son université du nord de
l'italie et par goût de la provocation
ce professeur de chimie à fabriquer un
suaire conformes dit il en tout point à
celui de turin pour montrer qu'un tel
objet pouvait être fabriqués avec les
techniques du moyen-age qui veulent
croire à l'authenticité du suaire
continueront à y croire contre toute
évidence
d'ailleurs il ya encore des gens qui
pensent que la terre est plate qu'il
soit authentique ou pas le suaire de
turin attire les foules on attend ici
près de deux millions de personnes
jusqu'au 23 mai pour contempler ce qui
reste l'un des plus grands mystères de
la foi et de la science la fin de
l'expédition pour jean louis etienne qui
s'est posé avec son ballon ce matin en
sibérie partie
bergin explorateurs a parcouru plus de
3000 kilomètres au dessus du pôle nord
il a recueilli des informations durant
ce périple sur le dérèglement climatique
nous retrouverons en demain afin qu'il
nous raconte son fabuleux voyage depuis
cinq ans le club du 21e siècle travail
pour la reconnaissance des minorités au
sein des entreprises publiques et
privées
aujourd'hui l'organiser à paris des
rencontres avec des lycéens et le monde
du travail leur volonté donner une autre
image de l'immigration alors qu'est ce
que tout cela veut dire reportage
estelle cola et mature et y ait quitté
la banlieue pour les quartiers huppés de
la capitale pour les meilleurs d'entre
eux c'est le début de l'aventuré enfants
d'immigrés issus de minorités ou de
familles défavorisées
il était aujourd'hui à milliers venus de
lycées difficiles à fouler le sol de
sciences po charlotte bonne élève d'un
lycée de banlieue est venue accompagnée
de sa mère dans sa famille personne ne
lui a jamais parlé de ces filières
d'exception j'ai jamais abordé le sujet
avec ma famille j'ai même pas vers quel
métier ça aboutit c'est vraiment quelque
chose de vide
je connais on ne savait pas trop ce que
voulait dire à chaud c'est hélas
or le mans à la maison donc en même
temps c'est vraiment quelque chose que
je fais les fesses tu qu'on n'en parle
pas face à elle
l'élite des chefs d'entreprises
banquiers entrepreneurs aux
fonctionnaires phone 7 coréenne arrivé
en france à l'âge de 6 mois
énarque un modèle de réussite physique
nous avons cette initiative parce que
nous sommes très favorables à la
méritocratie est très attaché au mieux
et au cra 6 mai le pensons que l'accès
aux dispositifs et aux mécanismes de
promotion sociale n'est pas égal n'est
pas également assurer toutes les franges
de la population
le but aller chercher les talents là où
ils sont ils compris de l'autre côté du
périphérique astria 20 ans originaire du
congo termine sa première année à
sciences po
une fierté pour sa famille cette
occasion se présentait le niveau pour
pas aller si facile ou la cheville aller
jusqu'au bout ces face à face ont fait
leurs preuves
l'amphithéâtre de sciences politiques
depuis 2001 a accueilli sur ses beaux
quelques 600 élèves de quartiers
défavorisés
le sport rugby clermont a raté de peu la
marche pour les demi finales la coupe
d'europe hier soir face aux irlandais de
la sphère défaite 29 à 28
en revanche cet après midi les joueurs
de biarritz qui jouait à saint sébastien
ont remporté leur match face à l'équipe
galloise de neath swansea ospreys le
score eh bien cette fois encore il est
de 29 à 28
demain ils seront 33 miel à se lancer
sur le macadam pour le marathon paris un
défi pour de nombreux amateurs
arrivé au bout des 42 km et cela en
effectuant le meilleur temps pour cela
ils s'entraînent chaque semaine courir
courir encore courir après quoi après
qu' à chacun son choix aaron transit
virginie travers
depuis combien de temps une heure et
demie vous arrêter quand j'avais fait
ils ont envahi nos rues plus de deux
millions de français sont adeptes du
jogging avec son chien seul ou en groupe
courir c'est facile on va faire un conte
avait comparé le matin 8h faut
s'organiser c'est compliqué si on veut
courir voilà en france à faire le
bastiais contrat que la porte s'est
rendu là parce que le plus dur c'est les
3/4 première fois une fois qu'on a
commencé
c'est je pense et c'est bien comme une
drogue c'est difficile de s'arrêter sous
son bureau de travail
les baskets ne sont jamais très loin
cinq fois par semaine entre midi et deux
ou le soir marie parcourir entretenir
son physique et son moral et c'est vrai
quoi les jours où j'ai prévu d'y aller
et que je peux pas y aller parce que ya
toujours des arts y ait toujours des
impératifs qu'ils soient professionnels
ou personnels bas un peu frustré un peu
frustrant et on ressent clairement comme
un bang manque drogue elle l'explication
et scientifique
après une demi heure de course le
cerveau libère des endorphines et de la
dopamine et c'est endorphines joue un
rôle au fort is an si vous voulez quand
l'exercice arrête on n'est pas très bien
quand on est dépendant du coup il ya une
chute de celles d'opel mines est on
obligé de courir pour éviter ce désordre
cérébrale demain avec son père marie
participera à son premier marathon 42 km
le four marchande on finira et comme ils
seront plus de 33000 à souffrir avec une
vue imprenable sur les plus beaux
monuments de paris le cinéma ce soir
avec un sourire qui nous vient des états
unis elle est devenue une amie pour
certains et certaines qui l'ont suivi
dans la série friends depuis des années
mais aussi une femme qui est l'une des
égéries des magazines féminins du monde
entier jennifer aniston est notre invité
ce soir
elle vient nous présenter son dernier
film le chasseur de primes
bonsoir merci beaucoup d'être là ce soir
alors vous avez peut-être pas eu le
temps de vous rendre compte que
finalement aux états unis en europe en
france
vous êtes extrêmement populaire est-ce
que de temps en temps quand vous êtes
chez vous vous posez cette question de
savoir mais pourquoi suis-je aussi
populaire finalement et bien honnêtement
lorsque je suis chez moi simplement chez
moi c'est pas le genre de question que
je me pose c'est quelque chose que l'on
remarque lorsqu'on est hors de chez soi
justement parce que je suis dans ma
voiture ou ailleurs dans le monde
mais si on ne fait pas attention si on
ne fait pas attention ce qui se passe
dans les médias et je crois qu'il vaut
mieux ne pas le faire d'ailleurs
ça peut être étouffant parfois il faut
rester les pieds sur terre
alors ce qui se fait ou font ça peut
effectivement honnête oui bien sûr ça
peut être mais en même temps ça fait
partie de mon métier je crois en même
temps cette proximité
cette popularité elle est peut-être due
à l'histoire que vous avez semé au fil
du temps notamment avec ce feuilleton
fred ce qui vous arrange rendu tellement
proche des gens parce que ce que vous
viviez dans ce feuilleton
c'était en fait ce que vivait toute une
génération en fait j'ai grandi devant
les yeux du public et
et il semblerait que les spéciales dans
la série c1 ressembler ce qui se passait
dans la vie des gens aussi c'est sûr
alors vous venez nous présenter votre
dernier film comédie rythmée l'histoire
de votre ex qui est devenu chasseur de
primes et qui doit tout simplement vous
interpeller et vous ramener devant la
justice le film vu par isabelle bechler
et peut on se retrouve juste après ces
drôles de tomber sur toi ici
il était l'époux et josette équipe mais
le flic et la journaliste ont négligé
leur mariage ou si pep je vais
rencontrer c'est parce que tu mouilles
haute mais moi j'ai passé et mon nouveau
boulot c'est traquer les criminels sur
tous les crétins qui se présente pas au
tribunal car les chasseurs de brive toi
la course-poursuite peut commencer
ce que milow n'était pas c'est que son
ex et sur une enquête délicate et
dangereuse
leurs aventures vont aussi raviver leurs
sentiments un an après le divorce d'un
amour pour elle les ja ma mort en fait
lycées les trains gay s'est transformée
en colère alors qu'au fond il était
toujours amoureuse elle est dans le déni
ennemi même à bois souffert quoi tu va
tirer sur moi c'est tiré sur la chauffer
film d'action mais surtout une comédie
où les deux interprètes principaux font
toutes les cascades eux-mêmes suis un
peu plus au fur et à mesure de l'action
en conflit tombe nos egos émoussé suse
nous devons compter l'un sur l'autre les
événements nous rappellent à quel point
nous formions une super équipe
la journaliste ne s'avoue jamais vaincu
je voulais juste te remercie pour une
soirée vraiment vraiment charmante
logique
le chasseur de primes est parfois pris à
son propre jeu jusqu'à un happy end
plutôt prévisible
alors jennifer stone ça vous fait
parfois sourire dans votre voix
françaises comme ça vous avez vous
habitez dans une bonne voie dans toutes
les langues
non c'était intéressant
j'aime bien sa voix j'aime beaucoup
cette voie alors vous aimez les comédies
vous en avez fait plusieurs depuis
quelques années
qu'est ce qu'elle est particulier celles
aller un peu plus rythmée encore que les
autres on a entre l'action et
effectivement la comédie
bien ce qui m'a attiré dans ce projet ce
n'est pas comme anti classique c'est
plutôt une comédie d'action avec un peu
de romans c'est ce qui m'a plu une
romance particulière parce que
finalement vous devez essayer de séduire
entre guillemets votre ex-mari qui est
devenu chasseur de primes et qui doit
entre guillemets vous ramener vers la
justice
un jeu particulier oui c'est un jeu
particulier j'essaye en fait de lui
échapper plus tôt le 7 juillet je dirais
ce qui est très bien c'est que ce couple
est finalement se découvrent ils
redécouvrent ce qu'ils faisaient mais
chez l'un chez l'autre tout au long du
film tu te monde cette chaîne et de
cette poursuite
ils se re découvre on voit beaucoup de
séries américaines qui sont allés
formaté pour passer au cinéma
est-ce que c'est envisageable et là je
sais qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
attendent la réponse de voir un jour
friends passé là on va dire au format
géant oui je sais j'ai entendu parler de
l'éventualité où on nous a dit qu'il
faudrait le faire mais ce ne sont que
des rumeurs pour le moment tout cas pas
les rumeurs on va rester pour le moment
sur les rumeurs merci beaucoup jennifer
aniston devenu sur ce plateau nous faire
un petit coucou lors de votre passage à
paris cela s'appelle donc chasseur de
primes isla sort mercredi
merci à vous merci beaucoup et à très
bientôt voilà pour cette interview
réalisée lors du passage de la star à
paris il a fait beau aujourd'hui un peu
partout en france des températures à la
hausse 16 à paris 18 ajaccio 18 à
montélimar et même 22 à bordeaux
direction justement la gironde entre le
bassin d'arcachon et le cap ferret où
l'on a appris un peu le temps est bien
de respirer
reportage david base
bernard bonne arme sur les cales de mise
à l'eau d'arcachon comme sur les routes
le retour du beau temps rime avec
embouteillages sont pêcheurs ils
s'arment donc de patience et
qu'aujourd'hui
oleg et certains ont les pieds dans
l'eau mais pas le bon bateau on va aller
faire du jazz fitr c'est le bateau d'un
monsieur que je me garde en l'attendant
soleil 20 degrés malgré le petit vent
frais tous les éléments de la carte
postale sont réunis l'horizon lointain
les amoureux et les crabes pour les
épuisettes des enfants a décrit viennent
d'une heure alors un essai des vacances
d'une heure actuellement c'est samedi la
plage n'est pas encore bondée les
maillots de bain encore rares mais les
plaisirs sont ceux de l'été
là je reste aux larcins soleil j'avais
décidé ce matin partir d'essais hier
soir pourquoi mon avis la météo on
n'avait rien de spécial en coin c'est
d'y aller un embarquement sur la liaison
d'arcachon le cap ferret une traversée
de paysages magnifiques qui est aussi
une vraie ligne de transport c'est très
beau de les voir des gens qui vont
arrivés par le train qu'on va
transporter jusque
jusqu au cap ferret avec leurs valises
donc avec les valises les passagers à
bord sont des touristes de bourgogne
aujourd'hui cap ferret hier c'était dune
du pilat voilà donc un petit peu tout ce
qui est autour d' arcachon arrivée au
cap ferret et en qui concerne la
baignade
un seul ou presque y est allé c'est lui
bravo température de l'eau 12 degrés
voilà avant de se quitter je vous
rappelle l'information que ce samedi
c'est cette catastrophe aérienne qui a
coûté la vie au président polonais lech
kaczinsky qui se rendait en russie pour
les cérémonies commémorant le drame de
katyn catastrophe qui a coûté la vie à
une centaine de passagers parmi lesquels
l'épousé du chef de l'état mais
également de nombreux hauts dignitaires
du pays
ce soir des dizaines de milliers
polonais sont réunis sur la principale
place de varsovie et devant le palais
présidentiel
une semaine de deuil national a été
décrétée voit la fin de sa démission
merci à vous d'avoir suivi tout de suite
la météo isabelle martinez 20h35
l'aventuré inattendue de patrick
sabatier en compagnie de michèle bernier
ce soir rendez vous demain à 13h pour
l'essentiel de l'information passé une
très belle soirée et à demain j'espère
l'info en continu
c'est aussi sur france 2 point fr sur
france 2 600 jeux comment je me sens je
me sens j'ai un trac l'aventuré
inattendue de michèle bernier avec
patrick sabatier
la comédienne n'est pas au bout de ses
surprises tout de suite france 2
présente comble de rêve avec velux
c'est sous un toit de poitiers qu'un
ministre atteint rêver de bande dessinée